>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington DC.
>> Georgette Dorn:
-- and others.
It is a great pleasure to
welcome here Lilia Schwarcz
and Bryan McCann and [inaudible]
study Guzman-Gonzalez,
who will introduce the speakers.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>>Talia Guzman-Gonzalez:
Thank you, Georgette.
And thank you to my colleagues
in the Hispanic division
for helping me organize and
putting this together for today.
It is my great pleasure to
welcome you all to this event
about one of Brazil's
most relevant authors
of the 20th century and
probably still today.
Alfonso Henriques
de Lima Barreto.
I can only imagine what Lima
would say about the fact
that we have all his books in
the largest library in the world
or that we're here
today talking about him,
talking about how important
he is and having Lilia
and Bryan here with us to engage
in a conversation
about his work.
Bryan McCann teaches Brazilian
history at Georgetown.
He's close by and he
has written widely
about Brazilian social
and cultural history.
He's the author of numerous
articles and books, including,
"Hard Times in the Marvelous
City, From Dictatorship
to Democracy in the Favelas
of Rio de Janeiro," published
in 2013, "The Throws of
Democracy, Brazil since 1989,"
published in 2008, and "Hello,
Hello, Brazil, Popular Music
in the Making of Modern
Brazil," from 2004.
He recently wrote
the introduction
for a new English translation
of Vida Vertiginosa,
Vertiginous Life,
by Joao do Rio,
who is a contemporary
of Lima Barreto.
And foe probably.
The book was published this
year by New London Librarian
and the translation
by Ana Lessa-Schmidt.
And thank you for calling
our attention to that
and we're getting on
it and all those books.
I'm very excited to have
Lilia Moritz Schwarcz here
in the library.
For me it's a great honor.
As a grad student both Bryan
and Lilia were both references,
so for me it's truly amazing
to have them here today.
She wears many hats
in her different roles
as an intellectual,
writer, publisher,
mentor and overall
force of nature.
She's a full professor
in the Faculdade de Filosofia
Letras e Ciencias Humanas
at the University of
Sao Paulo in Brazil.
Where she also received her
PhD in social anthropology.
Her main areas of research
are history of slaves,
racial theories, history of the
Brazilian empire, academic art
and history of anthropology.
She's the author, co-author
or editor of over 50 titles.
We have them here.
I search for them.
Some of them are
outside you can see them.
And they include Retrato
em branco e negro,
Portrait in White
and Black, from 1987,
A Longa Viagem da
Bibilioteca dos Reis from 2002,
The Long Journey of the King's
Library, O Sol do Brazil,
from 2008, The Son of
Brazil and the book
that brings us here
today, Triste Visionario,
Lima Barreto from 2017.
Three of her books are available
in English, so those of you
who cannot yet read
in Portuguese,
I welcome you to look them up.
Spectacle of Racist, Science
Institutions and Racial Theories
in Brazil at the end of the 19th
Century, The Emperor's Beard,
Pedros II, A Tropical
King, from 2004.
And Brazil, A Biography
is coming
out next year I just learned,
so, that's very exciting.
Lilia has also been the curator
of several important
exhibits throughout Brazil
on topics ranging from the
French Painter, Nicolas Taunay,
to Brazilian photography
and childhood histories.
She's currently curating
an exhibit
at the [speaking
foreign language] title,
[speaking foreign
language], which consists
of a yearlong programs of
exhibits, workshops and lectures
on the [speaking
foreign language],
I tried look up a translation.
I think, ebbs and flows.
Between Africa, the Americas,
the Caribbean and Europe.
We look forward to that in 2018,
if we can all go
to Brazil for that.
As you can imagine, all this
work has been recognized
with some of the most
important national
and international
prizes and fellowships,
including five Jabuti Prizes,
which is Brazil's
leading literary prize.
And the Brazilian
Academy of Letters Prize.
She also holds a
Guggenheim fellowship
from the Guggenheim Foundation
and the John Carter Brown
Library University fellowship
as well.
She's been a visitor at
Oxford, Leiden, Princeton
and Brown Universities, a Tinker
Professor at Columbia University
and since 2011 she
is Global Professor
at Princeton University.
She writes regularly for
the Brazilian newspapers,
Folha de S Paulo, Estado
de S. Paulo and Nexo.
And since 2015 she's a
co-curator for history
for the Museum of
Art in Sao Paulo.
Today she'll be here
talking about Lima Barreto.
After her talk we'll have a
conversation with Bryan McCann
and the audience, so
please stay for that.
Please join me in welcoming
Lilia to the Library.
[ Applause ]
>> Lilia Moritz Schwarcz:
Well, good afternoon.
Thank you so much.
Thank you, Talia, for this
beautiful introduction
to my biography.
Don't pay attention to her.
It's not true.
I just want to start thanking
this very honorable invitation
from the Hispanic Division
of the Library of Congress.
I want to mention Talia
Guzman-Gonzales [assumed
spelling] that took care
of really everything,
including my research today.
And also my colleague, Bryan
McCann, for the kindness
of being here to
discuss my presentation.
I agreed with Talia that I
would talk about my last book,
Lima Barreto, Sad
Vision, [inaudible].
I thought it would
be good to start
with the title, "Sad Visionary."
I wanted to put a
balance in the title.
For example, if you think
about sad, sad is a word
that Lima Barreto uses a lot.
Sad is the title of
his most famous novel,
"Triste Fim de Policaropo
Quaresma," the Sad End
of Policaropo Quaresma."
But sad in popular Brazil, it
means a person that is stubborn.
It's persistent.
That insists.
So you can see that you have
an ambivalence in one word.
Visionary, visionary
because, again,
Lima Barreto used
it a lot, this word.
Visionary.
Again, in Sad End of
Policaropo Quaresma,
there is a particular moment
when Floriano Peixoto,
our former president and a
character, evil character
of Lima Barreto, says
to Policaropo Quaresma,
"Policaropo, you
are a visionary.
I can't trust you,
it's not a compliment."
He's trying to say, so,
visionary can be a person
that sees the future, but a
visionary can also be a person
that is a fool, kind of lunatic.
So, you can see what kind of
problems I had in my book.
No, a biography is an
exercise of ambiguity.
No? It's another exercise of
being affected, to be distant,
to be very very closed
at the same time.
Lima Barreto [inaudible]
said, "It's not" --
it's a very well known
author in brazil,
a very well known writer,
and it was very well said it.
So, what I tried to do and
I tried to explain to you
in this afternoon, I tried
to come up with new questions
for the same character.
Questions that I think it's a
kind of thing of my generation,
my generation that we are
dealing with civil rights,
problems of civil rights.
So I asked Lima Barreto
about race, gender,
region and generation.
All social markers of difference
that I tried to put together
in a kind of intersection.
Let's see if I will succeed, no?
So, let me start
quoting Lima Barreto.
So, this is Lima
Barreto, "The republic
of Brazil was the
regime of corruption.
Nobody wants to debate,
nobody wants to stir up ideas.
Nobody wants to put any
real feeling into it.
Everybody wants a
slice of the action.
The jurists want their slice,
the philosophers
want their slice,
the doctor want their slice,
the novelists want their slice,
the engineerings
want their slice,
the journalists want their
slice, Brazil is one big apple.
All brazil, [speaking
foreign language]."
Let me try just a test on you.
The body and the style
are very present day,
in Brazil and also here.
But the piece itself it's
almost a 100 years old.
However current it may seem,
it was actually published --
let me just move --
published in 1918
in an [inaudible] magazine
called A.B.C. The title,
"A Political Publicana,
The Republican Politics,"
had a very clear target and
was signed by a colonist
of Brazil First Republic.
Famous for his very
critical style.
We are talking about
[speaking foreign language].
Lima, to his friends,
[speaking foreign language]
to his readers, but
also, Jonathan, Aaron,
[speaking foreign language],
that one, and [inaudible]
that barely conceal the
author's true identity.
They were his nick names.
Pick names, as he liked to joke.
Or [speaking foreign language].
Black by argent size,
and literature,
Lima Barreto brought black
antagonist into the foreground.
He felt the same thing that
was his own subjectivity
and was able to describe them
in color, sensitive terms.
I'm going to quote
Lima Barreto once more.
"They were simple seamen, low
ranking officers, white, blacks,
mulattos, [speaking
foreign language],
people of every color
and disposition.
Folks who had gotten themselves
mixed up in their adventure
out of the nasty habit of
doing what they are told.
This is comes from
[speaking foreign language].
In [inaudible] context, Lima
was a near solitary combatant
against racism in Brazil.
Against race [inaudible], that
was a big fashion in Brazil.
I quote him once more.
"A white man intellectual,"
he would say,
"is measured [inaudible],
a black man, [inaudible]."
In his novels, chronicles,
short stories, diaries,
Lima Barreto denounced the
discrimination he suffered,
that's of racist he
endured, great or small
and in the sense his
literature was solidary,
as he would say, militant.
Freedom was a concept dear to
Lima Barreto, who from a line
of slaves on both sides.
His grandfather,
Manuel Feliciano [speaking
foreign language] had actually
owned his grandmother and never
recognized the relationship,
as it was all too common
in Brazilian history
of which we only know one
side, the maternal side.
His father, [speaking foreign
language] was a type setter
during the Brazilian empire
and the proud inventor
of a special phones
created especially
for the printing
of the layout in.
The golden law.
The empire's most popular
and indeed less law.
As the republic we'll begin in
1989 and the layout was in 1888.
Lima's mother, -- oh,
this is the golden law.
Lima's mother, Dona Amalia,
was a granddaughter of slaves.
She trained as a teacher
and became head mistress
of the Sintahoza
[phonetic spelling] school
for girls in Laranjeiras.
The Barretos therefore belonged
to those African Brazilian
families who believed
that true freedom would
come to education,
not with a cold letter
of the law.
On the fridge of the system
there was no room for such forms
of social mobility, even
if they steal the pendant
on a certain kind of patronage.
And that was what happened
in the two sides of
Barreto's family.
Both having perfections
and social alliance
with powerful families
of [inaudible] Province
and later state.
Laranjeiras, as you can
see is the neighborhood
where the Barretos would live.
And it was then a highly
diversified neighborhood,
socially speaking, as can be
seen from the architecture
and the people in this photo.
However, fate would not
be kind to the family.
Dona Amalia died from
tuberculosis in 1887,
leaving her widower,
Joao Henriques
to raise the three kids alone.
Even so, Joao Henriques
didn't neglect his
children's education.
On the day of the golden law,
there he was with his son
at his side, turned out to
watch the pomp and the ceremony.
It was an event that Lima would
rewrite on many occasions.
On one of these he recalled
how Miss Theresa, his teacher,
came into the class and declared
that there were no
more slaves in Brazil.
Still only a boy, Lima got
the wrong end of the stick.
He arrived home and informed
his father that from that day
on he could no longer
ground him.
[speaking foreign language].
The future would not be rosy
for Lima and his family.
[speaking foreign language]
the godson of Ouro Preto,
the cabinet chief of the
last imperial government,
fell along with his
protector, becoming one
of the first unemployed
of the second Reich.
Even so, he managed to
find an administrative post
at a mad house on
Ilna do Governador.
That's the house.
That's the house nowadays.
Madness, real and social,
social and real, became a fixer
to Lima Barreto's life
from that point on.
And he would never shrink
from criticizing the mad house
system was, as he often claimed,
a micro cause of wider society.
Shot through with the
same social, political
and racial differences.
At asylum he would say often,
"Black was always the
harshest culture."
"The asylum," he wrote, "was
a place for invisibility."
Black invisibility.
Lima Barreto studied in
good schools from this --
as this one in Niteroi.
Fulfilled his father's dream, he
was accepted in the Politecnica.
The engineering program.
Where he claimed
where he suffered
for the first time
discrimination.
This is Politecnica.
This is a very rare photography
of the Lima Barreto group.
Lima Barreto is there
on the right side
and you can see him here.
Yeah. In this time torn photo
we see Lima wearing a large tie
and a borrowed jacket
looking into the future.
He who claimed not to belong
to this select chick group,
with this European style elite
that refused to accept him.
Unfortunately, Lima would have
no time to finish the course.
In 1902 having failed
to balance the books
on [speaking foreign language],
Joao Henriques, Lima's father,
was forced into retirement.
The boy left the Politecnica and
entered public life as a clerk.
With a war -- he was a
clerk in the war office,
a place he always hated.
What he really wanted was to
make a living from literature.
He wrote in his diary,
he wrote in his diary,
"I will marry literature."
The civil service struck
him as a waste of time.
Marry a bread and butter job.
I'm going to quote once
more, "We are all born
to the civil service, that
[inaudible], no conflict
or violent [inaudible],
five hours of plain sailing
every day, [inaudible] for life.
All of that sits perfectly well
with our expectations
and temperament.
In a day's work for the state
there is no unpredictability
and replies, no extra
effort to get
up to [inaudible] to tomorrow.
Everything precedes calmly and
smoothly, with no collisions,
no surprise, as one goes
about drafting the same papers
and memorandums,
the same decrees
in the very same
fashion all year long.
Save for bank holidays,
holidays and optional holidays,
clearly one of the best
inventions of our republic."
So, he set about
reinventing himself.
He moves to Todos os
Santos, literally all saints,
though he claimed the saints had
long since abandoned the place.
At the same time from that
day on he was used to take --
to take the central
station train every day.
That was an extended
huge generator
that includes the suburb.
In fact, Lima Barreto started to
write a literature in transit.
In -- and he used to
-- but this is a line
of the Central do Brazil
and you see Rio de Janeiro,
that is the zero mark and then
Todos os Santos in the middle
and then this is a second
class car that he used to say,
"the second class car in the
morning is black, all black."
Lima Barreto became
also a secretary
with a very fashionable
magazine called Fon Fon.
Then promptly he resigned.
He used to say that he didn't'
like having his copies
constantly being.
But his real work, his real
challenge was literature.
And in 1909 he had
already written two novels.
But he decided to start
with the "Recollections
of the Clerk, Isaias Caminha."
That he found more aggressive.
Lima had this kind of capacity
to make noise, a lot of noise.
"Isaias Caminha" is the story
of a boy, the son of a priest
and the slave mother,
who goes to the big city
to make something of himself.
And runs up against prejudice.
Skin changes, he wrote.
In the second part of
the book he picks a fight
with the journalist,
[inaudible],
when normally sitting,
Oh Global, the newspaper,
Oh Global, he attacks the
newspaper he wrote it for
and the colleagues
he worked with.
Including John [inaudible].
He was immediately
blacklisted and had the doors
of the big press
slammed to his face.
But he, in his way, was
a stubborn person and set
up a magazine of
his own, Floreal.
Which lasted only four issues,
and Lima thanked the
35 loyal subscribers
who had stayed the course.
Lima fell in with a group
of friends who used to hang
out around the bars downtown.
And together they went by the
name of Confedia [inaudible].
Con fraternity of clerks.
The group of drinking
buddies used to come together
to exchange the user to say
useless theories and ideas.
They used it to be seen in
a particular bar called,
"Bi Papagaiyou [assumed
spelling], the Parrots Bar.
Lima often mentioned that
even the Papagaiyou, the bird,
liked to drink a
lot and in this kind
of situation the parrot used
it to blame against republic.
I do not know if this is true
or this is Lima, but he's trying
to fictionalize his own life.
But the thing is the
group like very much --
the group was a kind of creating
a new kind of modernist,
a new kind of way of seeing
Brazil, to transporting Brazil.
But Lima Barreto he wrote,
"Nume e a Nympha" in 1911
and attacked the politicians.
And he wrote "Dr.
Bogoloff" in 1912,
when he attacked the Brazilians
and called the Brazilians
Botherrists.
He used to say that the
resilience loved just
to import ideas and theories.
In 1914 Lima could
not hold out no longer
and was committed
for the first time.
He was found drunk and
his brother decided
to put him in the hospital.
There admittance office,
perhaps as a curtsey
for one civil servant
to another,
registered him as white.
And that adds that Lima had
presented himself as a writer.
He says he's a writer.
That he wrote.
But Lima was not a loser at all.
And then in 1911 he started
publishing Policarpo Quaresma
[speaking foreign language].
And then in 17 he published
this book, this as a book.
The book is a story of a sort
of Brazilian [speaking
foreign language].
A critic of what he
called sheep [inaudible].
In the book was well received,
but not as well as
Lima had expected.
So he wrote in his diary,
"Policarpo Quaresma,
the idea that kills the
deception with pessimism."
By these days his life was
more than jumbled with those
of his character --
of his characters.
He was as Isaias Caminha
and he was Gonzaga
Desa [assumed spelling]
and the opposite was
nonetheless true.
But the experience in the
hospital was really profound.
He was a critical voice
against racial theories,
like the ones right
-- that was written
by Nina Rodriguez
[assumed spelling],
that Nina Rodriguez
is a professor
of the faculty of
the [inaudible].
That the defendant in Brazil,
was creates that generation.
He also was -- this
is the magazine
of Nina Rodriguez called
Brazil Madico Magazine.
And here you can see images
of some of the colleagues
of Lima Barreto in the hospital.
Lima wrote a special diary about
his experience in the hospital
and he used it to describe
the colleagues he had
in the hospital, saying, "In
the hospital all I can see
is brown."
And eventually he wrote,
"Constitution is not for us."
By the state of his life he
was really mixing everything.
But life went on and Lima
kept looking to find a niche
for himself in this
Republic of Letters.
In 1917 he was already
an anarchist
and was emotionally caught
of the stripes of 17.
He wrote article defending
the worker's class,
the worker's right and
also defended a kind
of military leader, very much
influenced by the context.
He declares himself
with Dostoyevsky,
Balzac, Flobare, [inaudible].
Lima defended as social
leader to very much connected
with the problems of his time.
One has to recognize that Lima
Barreto was becoming really a
public face of the republic.
Then in 1919 another collapse.
And there he was again
committed or "kidnapped"
as he put it, once again.
He was still a critic of racial
theories, but he was shaken
to the point to recognize
certain signs of irratity.
As an anarchist with a
[inaudible] for a mother
and a madman for a father,
he admitted, just once,
that he had signs of
degeneration to machination.
In this moment he wrote,
"Sometimes I'm afraid
that my body is betraying me."
At this time he looked
really tired.
There is one interesting point
that I want to stress to you.
In 1914 he was described
as a white person.
In 1919, four years and a
half later, he was admitted
as a pardo [assumed spelling].
Pardo, this kind of color,
that is almost impossible
to translate.
It's a kind of etc.
of the senses.
It's a kind of the none of
the others of the senses.
Social color is the
term we use to talk
about this way the Brazilians
negotiate with color.
In a positive or sometimes
in a very negative agency.
In his diary he often
wrote the names
of his characters,
instead of his own.
And in his novella his
own name, instead of those
of his character, only
to scratch it out again.
You can see in this document,
you can see this is the
Cemittery of the Living.
The last book Lima Barreto was
writing that he couldn't finish.
And I don't know if you
can see, he puts his name,
it's a long one, he puts his
name there, Lima Barreto,
and then he puts -- an opposite
thing is also true in his diary.
Sometimes he puts the names
of the fictional characters
instead of his own name.
The thing is Lima Barreto was
really really fictionalizing
his life.
We are now in 1922 and in this
year so important and symbolic
to Brazil, Lima met
his own [inaudible].
He finished Clara dos Anjos.
Which would be his most
suburban and feminist novel.
Lima was working on this novel
since he started
writing his diary, in 19.
At this time eventually
he started the diary,
with a beautiful sentence.
He wrote, "When I started
writing this diary a
hope landed."
Lima Barreto was a
writer with such a strong
and powerful [inaudible]
but never married.
Though he often dreamed of his
grandmother and his mother.
As for Clara dos Anjos, there
was many versions of this novel.
The less of which they
had sprung to 1922
and sees the dreamy
mulatto Clara dos Anjos,
that we look pregnant,
alone, sad, very sad.
In 1921 Lima Barreto had already
retired from the war office
and was working as a writer.
He counted the days, the hours,
the minutes he lost
as a public servant.
The last time he was seen
in the [speaking foreign
language] de Janeiro he was
covered in the celebrations
around the Brazilian
Centenary of 1922.
Of which, of course,
he disapproved.
He found it an example
of fake patriotism,
mixed with a nationalist
sentimentalist most Brazilians
had from being [inaudible].
The same year he
come into contact
with the publicists modernist.
Whose magazine Klaxon he
received from the hands
of [speaking foreign language].
The future very well,
non-Brazilian historian,
and literary critic.
He didn't like it at all.
He thought it was
named after a horn,
and a horn we call him a
car, which meant [inaudible]
and the code to the foreign.
He [inaudible] it and
in return took a beating
in the [inaudible] Klaxon.
This was the beginning of a
difficult future reception,
that consigned Lima Barreto
to the [inaudible] modernist.
Which was pretty
much no place at all.
Something that never
was and never would be.
To make matters worse
he was lumped
into this category,
along with writers.
He did not identify with them,
such as [inaudible] and worst
of all [speaking
foreign language].
But this kind of reception
would take its time.
We are now in November
22 and Lima Barreto,
who was always worried
he wouldn't be able
to cover the cost of
his father's funeral,
died a day in a half
before his old man.
With a copy of [speaking
foreign language], two words,
magazine, on his hands.
Fitting enough for someone
who lived between two worlds.
And so in neither at all.
When he was in the suburbs
he missed the [inaudible].
He disagreed with the Brazilian
Academy of Letter and tried
to enter the institution
three times, and failed.
Lima crafted the
characters of his books
with an immense tenderness.
They were rather different to
the ones the public was used to.
There even religions mixed with
the prevailing catholisist.
They were very skin toned,
and black and they lived
on the outskirts of the
city, which resonated
with the African [inaudible].
And the short story called,
[speaking foreign language],
the Boy, for example,
Lima tenderly describes the
lands of his own neighbors.
[inaudible].
Not far from there you
had the voodoo shacks
and deposits of ancestral
beliefs.
They go and mixing African
religions with spirits.
They spread like wildfire.
The Catholic Church does not
satisfy our humble people.
the priest fought most of our
people can't really communicate
with the divine, but the medium,
the warlock, the witch doctor,
if they don't deceive
divinity in their trances they
at least receive spirits and
souls, which being no longer
of this world are closer to god
and therefore partake a little
of his eternal and
immense wisdom.
He also liked to see
himself as a rebel.
On principle for fun
and to irritate [speaking
foreign language].
Oh, this is the --
this is the retake
of [speaking foreign language].
He was against pompous
politicians,
against the new aristocracy and
against cosmetic journalist,
against [inaudible] literature,
against [inaudible] and so,
he suddenly railed against
metropolis [speaking foreign
language] and [inaudible].
He denounced the abuse of
society committed against women,
but accused feminism of being
a sheep importation in Brazil.
He defended simple habits,
but disliked soccer,
Zumba and Carnival.
He detests civil servants,
yet learned his living
as a war office [inaudible].
Despised his deplorable
handwriting,
he had a terrible
handwriting for a clerk.
In fact, in [speaking foreign
language] the life and death
of [speaking foreign language]
published in 1918 on the pretext
of summarize the works of
his department, Lima embarked
on a hilarious reflection on the
job he did for so many years.
On my first day at the war
office I realized very clearly
that we are all born
for the civil service.
So, same as less was my adaption
that I felt as though I had come
into this world for
no other reason
than to put my limited
grammar and office [inaudible]
to the service of the
state and its mission
to regulate the march
of the nation.
Basically that was Lima
Barreto in a nutshell.
For a full of contradiction,
full of his own subjectivities,
but with very firm notions,
theories, thesis, idiosyncrasies
and pains and dreams
and products.
Lima didn't' experience
slavery at very close quarters,
not like his two grandmothers.
It was at asylum that he learned
from his fellow inmates
the importance
of understanding what
he called his origins.
[speaking foreign
language] who used
to call Lima [speaking foreign
language] had made some money
selling his master's
groceries at the market.
And when the time was
right he uses his savings
to buy his freedom.
Sometime later he fell in
love with Maria Pollina
and bought her freedom too.
They moved in together and
all was going swimmingly
until she left him.
Then came his [inaudible].
That was the state [inaudible]
was in when he met the author.
As Lima tell us, [inaudible] was
quite a figure and he writes,
"Many other facts of this
kind pass between us,
and now that this pair
besets me, I can recall --
I can't recall that unique
black fellow without thinking
that what gives life
its charm more
than anything else is
the candle of the simple
and the resignation
of the hammer."
In his self-styled militant
autobiographical literature Lima
ended becoming and living
out his own characters.
He was each of them in turn
and all of them at once.
And also none of them at all.
Lima was in a hurry.
His literature, he
was in a hurry.
Of course, he had no way of
knowing that he would die
at the age of 41 from an
alcoholic induced heart attack.
Life was short.
His literature will live longer.
He was an author who, as
the critic used it to say,
confessed the whole time.
But he did much more than that.
He was a man of his time,
the sort that becomes
at once a witness to an activist
of the period in which he lived.
A writer who wrote with
feeling and with soul.
Feeling the creative
sense of perfect.
It's impossible to read Lima
Barreto without being affected
by him, without being swept
up on his own magical carpet.
Blurring the most of his borders
between fiction and non-fiction,
Lima Barreto showed us
another visual or another side
to the one we know very well.
The Brazil of the big hearted
as Manuel [speaking
foreign language].
Sharing on its shoulders a
word of pain, but which refuses
to take it lying down.
On the contrary, of Brazil,
let's stand up and fight.
T he republic he watch less
was not the one he dreamt
and -- sorry, dreamt of.
It became in its own
way [inaudible] racist,
all toward looking in,
above all, deeply unjust.
[speaking foreign
language] once wrote
that the best witnesses
are those
who stay behind to
tell the tale.
More specifically those
who bring the past
into the present and vice versa.
In the case of Lima Barreto
all similarity is not
mere coincidence.
But before I finish
this presentation,
let me also conclude how
Lima Barreto continued
to be very contemporary,
even after almost 100 year.
Brazil -- in fact, Brazil
cannot blame it all on the past,
but Brazil is still a sample
[inaudible] social inequality
and practice of structural
racism.
Poor people, especially
in Tibet, black poor,
are far more likely to be
condemned in the courts
than to die younger,
have more limited access
to public higher education,
and are far less likely
to hold executive positions.
I don't want to bother
you with numbers,
but let me introduce
a few of them.
A few examples.
Why there has been a general
uptake in life expectancy
in Brazilian population,
the increase has not been
equal across the board.
High mortality rates
caused by urban violence,
among the male population,
particularly the young
black population,
and precarious access
to medical treatment
and healthcare have
both taken their too.
In general, 92% of the
victims of [inaudible] violence
in Brazil were young and male.
Moreover, if you take the
population as a whole,
the black youth is by
far the most likely
to die a violent death.
While in 2012 the murder rate
among the white youth was 29%
per 1000 inhabitants.
Practically same as
to the population.
The figure for black
youth was 82%.
It's not just a matter
of comparing per
capita death rates.
There is a very giant gulf
between these two groups
when it comes to assessing
the risk of murder.
Today a young black man in
Brazil is 2.5 times more likely
to be killed than
a young white man.
In the northeast of the
country, where murder rates tend
to be higher, the
difference is doubled.
A young black man
in the northeast
of Brazil is 5 times more likely
to be murdered than a white man
of the same age in
the same state.
Translated into absolute
figures,
what we see over 56,000
murders per year in Brazil.
30,000 of those kids
are youth ages
between 15 and 29 years old.
And 75% of those are black.
So we have a very
specific color and age bias
in annual murders rates.
And it's sadly in line with the
nation historical inequality.
The data also leaves no
doubt as to the vulnerability
and limited access to rise among
this part of the population.
Let me move on -- if I
would move to literacies,
I could give other data.
If I would go to racial
inequality in schools,
I will prove you
that race is a plus.
If we talk about what we
consider extremely poor
in Brazil, once again
inequality is considerable here.
7.2 of the black
population classifies
as extremely poor,
against 3% of whites.
What we see here is one of
many examples of continuity
between the slave owned past,
then post-evolution
period and the present.
I could talk about access to
public and private healthcare,
pencil and benefit systems,
position in job markets,
formal and informal
employment, domestic labor.
Inequality is too
real in Brazil.
In sum, in work,
birth, death, health,
race is always a kind of plus.
Data goes above --
underlies the reality
of discrimination
and racism in Brazil.
It points to urgent
demands for policies
to promote greater racial
equality as [inaudible],
use it to ask for in the
beginning of the 20th century.
A country more inclusive,
plural, a real democracy,
and not a republic, as Lima
Barreto used to ask for in 1922.
Thank you very much.
[ Applause ]
>> Bryan McCann: Thank
you so much, Lilia,
that was really wonderful.
And thank you to
Lilia for inviting me.
It's a huge honor and
a privilege to be here
with Lilia Schwarcz,
it's really one
of the most esteemed historians
and authors in Brazil.
This is an extraordinary
pleasure for me.
Thank you so much.
>> Lilia Schwarcz: Thank you.
>> Bryan McCann:
And congratulations
on this amazing new biography.
I really love your description
of asking new questions
of the same character,
because I think
that perfectly describes
this challenge
of how can we say something
new about one of the best loved
and best known authors
in Brazil.
And I think you've really
brought that out today
by showing us a Lima Barreto
who really is very current
and who has so much to say
about racial injustice in Brazil
and inequality in Brazil.
And we've known this, of course,
this has been acknowledged
about Lima Barreto before,
but I think you're bringing it
out in a different way.
So, I'd like to ask a
few questions about that.
Before getting into that
though, my first question is
about this categorization of
Lima Barreto as pre-modernist.
Which seems strange
based on this talk,
because you're showing us all of
these things about Lima Barreto
that are so current
and so cutting edge.
So, why did people describe
him as pre-modernist?
Where did that come from?
>> Lilia Schwarcz: Thank
you so much, Bryan.
I tried to explain the problem
Lima Barreto faced in 22,
22 was not a good
year for Lima Barreto.
And Lima Barreto was a very
well known literary critic
in the First Republic of Brazil.
That's why [inaudible] I wanted
to give him the magazine,
because they wanted
him to write a review
and to publicize the
Klaxon, and huge genre.
Reality between [inaudible]
was too much different
at the moment.
It was far away and it was the
dialogue it was very rarified.
It was not vivid
as it is nowadays.
So, [inaudible] the intention
of [inaudible] the intention
of the modernist
is the publicists,
coming from the publicist
modernist was
to create this kind -- to
have Lima Barreto writing
about this new magazine and
the modernist in Sao Paul.
And then what happens, Lima
Barreto had this title,
"Lima Barreto's Style."
It was always like this.
He started saying, "Oh, this
is a beautiful occasion to talk
about this new magazine.
Congratulations."
Then he started saying
terrible things about them.
And then at the end he
says things like this, "Oh,
but then I have to
congratulate you again."
So, this was very much Lima --
now we [inaudible] wrote a --
organized a book about Lima
Barretos, the literary critic.
So that is very impressive.
What happens?
The modernists didn't like it.
And Lima Barreto didn't
like the publicists.
I am publicist, so I can't talk,
I can't blame the
publicists, no?
He used to say, for
example, he used it to call,
[speaking foreign language],
like this grass [inaudible],
the terrible writer I am.
And he used it to say that
publicists were all capitalists,
they wanted stupid people.
And so on and on and on.
And then when he received
the magazine he blamed
the publicists.
And he received kind of answer
later on in a general part
of the newspaper,
very aggressive.
Completely trying to
say who Lima Barreto is.
And it sounded strange, because
Lima Barreto would be nobody.
Right? To deliver a magazine
to him to write about it.
So, there is a kind of noise.
And what happened later on, the
publicists, not in this moment
in 22, but if you
think about the 30s,
the publicist modernists became
a kind of measure and they used
to say, "This is the modern,
all the rest are not."
So they created this
category of prayer.
Prayer, almost.
And that was very terrible,
because they put
the same basket.
A lot of very different writers,
completely different writers
and that was very very
different for the reception
for Lima Barreto, because
if you think about it now,
Lima Barreto uses
the oral language.
Okay, if you read Clara dos
Anjos, the last book he signed,
he used it to introduce the
slangs, the expressions.
So very much -- very close
to the publicist moderns.
At the same time probably
the publicists would not
like this militant
style of Lima Barreto.
But even so, they
have some proximities.
And when the story of reception
of Lima Barreto was
very much different.
And in my opinion it started
with this particular problem.
>> Bryan McCann:
Thank you very much.
Another concept I wanted to
touch on that you brought
up is this idea of
[speaking foreign language]
of social color.
And you brought up a very
striking example of this,
the [speaking foreign
language] and the central line
from downtown Rio out to
the working class suburbs,
and Lima Barreto noting that
in the morning everybody
on that train is brown.
So, what is this
idea of social color
and how does it differ
from race?
>> Lilia Schwarcz: Well, in
Brazil, Brazil is a country
that defines -- we define
our country using colors.
No? We still have our senses
based on five colors, no?
Black, white, yellow, that
means people coming from Orient,
used to be red, now
it's [inaudible],
but red were native people,
and [speaking foreign language]
that is none of the others.
So, it's a very rational senses,
because if you cannot
describe you using your color,
then you describe you like
[speaking foreign language].
[speaking foreign
language] is a non-color.
Exactly a non-color.
And Brazil is doing a lot
of this kind of concept
of social color, social race.
In the end of the 70s,
beginning of the 80s we had
in Brazil a national census that
asked Brazilians about color.
And Brazilians came with
a 136 different colors.
And colors around the first
classification it would be a
kind of rainbow.
So the Brazilians would describe
themselves like white, black,
for those who purple,
green, browns.
And then also we had like
classifications in the middle,
like almost black, almost white,
white, black, white, white.
Coming to white, pushing
to black, pushing to white.
Unbelievable.
And then classifications
like this, [inaudible]
or [speaking foreign language].
It means nothing.
[speaking foreign language],
But it's not the translation.
It's in the -- I'm not
going to say my color.
So, Brazilians change,
play with color.
Depending on the place
you change your color, no?
Because of the famous singer
said, "You can be black
in some situations and
in others he's white."
The villain of Lima
Barreto called [speaking
foreign language].
Lima Barreto writes in a very --
it's unbelievable that
he wrote like this.
He writes Cassi was
white in the suburbs,
but when he took the train,
the central station and arrived
in the capital he was
black as though the suburb.
So, I'm not saying that this is
a good division, I'm not saying
that this is better than race.
I don't think it is --
I don't think there is
such a kind of good racism.
There is not.
This is just another
kind of racist.
I study soccer game in
[speaking foreign language],
that is the biggest
[inaudible] in South America.
And with different
divisions inside.
And during Christmas time I'm
going back to Brazilian time
to be there, they had
a soccer game called,
"Black Against White."
Formerly you had
11 white players
against 11 black players.
But depending on the year
people can change groups
as they change soccer.
And it's very difficult,
it's very difficult to deal
with this, because
often they play with me,
they ask< "Professor, can you
explain the color I have?"
But situations are becoming
more and more difficult,
because now in Brazil is now.
Because it's recent, no,
the racial question is
becoming an affirmative action,
black movement and becoming
very strong, very important.
And working with us,
with the idea of faults.
No? Proud that Lima
Barreto had in the beginning
of the 20th century, and
that's why he was considered
in the beginning of the 20th
century a very nasty person,
because he used it to say,
this is not a good subject.
Not a good point.
>> Bryan McCann: Thank you.
There's so many fascinating
things that come out of that.
I'm glad you brought up
this nefarious figure
of Cassi Jonas [assumed
spelling].
>> Lilia Schwarcz:
Yeah, Cassi Jonas.
>> Bryan McCann:
The evil character
of [speaking foreign language].
Why is he named Cassi Jones
and where does that come from
and how does that figure
into Lima Barreto's depiction
of not just race and
social color in Brazil,
but the local and the foreign?
>> Lilia Schwarcz: Yeah.
That's because Lima Barreto
used to read Flaubert,
[speaking foreign language] and
he used to read also Gautier,
that was a writer,
philosopher that wrote this kind
of theory, the Bovary's.
The Bovary is a theory of the
mania we have of being daughter,
no, playing daughter, no?
And playing we have French,
we are North American.
So, Lima Barreto was very much
against this kind of mania
that he used to say took the
Brazilian's lack of fever.
And he said -- Cassi Jones, so
he gave this name, Cassi Jones,
because he said,
Cassi Jones mattered.
Invented for herself a past, an
English past that she hadn't.
And, so, Cassi Jones
inherits this name and it --
that was a way for him to
play the white in the suburbs.
So it was a very
severe critic for this.
No? Also, he -- Cassi Jones
had this kind of cook fights.
He loved to breath --
>> Bryan McCann: Right,
cock fights, yeah.
>> Lilia Schwarcz: yeah.
And then that was an image
of Lima Barreto of the kind
of game, the games of wars.
That including -- that was the
reason he was against soccer,
because he used to say was
soccer would create prejudice
and we would create war.
Interesting if you
think how many problems
with racist we have now
when you see soccer games,
even in the United States.
You had a big event
here around this, no?
>> Bryan McCann: Right.
I'm going to limit myself
to just one more question.
I could keep this going,
but I know that other
people have questions.
So, it's hard to
pick just one more.
Bu there's so many interesting
potential comparisons
that come up, but one is this
haunting image of Lima Barreto
in the mental hospital.
And thinking of a
comparison with Lima Barreto
and Mashado Dajasheesh
[phonetic spelling]
very famous story
of [speaking foreign language].
>> Lilia Schwarcz: Yeah.
>> Bryan McCann: where the
psychiatrist comes to town
and starts putting people
in a mental hospital
and eventually everybody in
town is in a mental hospital,
eventually including the --
>> Lilia Schwarcz:
The psychiatrist.
>> Bryan McCann: the
psychiatrist himself.
And this is a metaphor
for Brazil
and it's a very popular
used metaphor.
How would you compare that to
Lima Barreto's own very vivid
and terrible experience
and his haunting depiction
of the mental hospital?
>> Lilia Schwarcz: Yeah.
Lima Barreto had this --
it's very interesting to see,
even the relationship
between Lima Barreto
and [inaudible] was very
difficult to say the least, no?
Every time you say -- I say,
"Oh, I'm studying Lima Barreto,"
there is a person that will come
to you, "so, you are very much
against Mashado Dajasheesh."
No, that's not true.
They don't need it.
But Lima Barreto he
in his private library he called
Le Mana [assumed spelling].
He had all Mashado
Dajasheesh books.
But he did not Mashado
Dajasheesh, he would say it,
so I'm just quoting him, was the
way Mashado Dajasheesh answered
in this institutional life, no?
But he wanted for him too,
but he couldn't have it.
So that's the difficulty
and the beauty
of this kind of character.
But then Lima Barreto has in his
Le Mana all the books he loved,
mainly the Russians, that
he used to read in French.
And he also had the books that
he did not like, did not enjoy.
He had all the books
of racial diverseness.
That's very much impressive.
He wanted to study.
He wanted to study in order
to understand and criticize.
He had Nina Rodriguez books.
Nina Rodriguez, no?
He -- in this book that I showed
the picture, the cover, he's --
that was the moment
that we were trying
to create a [inaudible] quote.
And he proposed two
panel quotes.
One for the blacks and one for
the whites, because he used
to say, "Crime is a
thing that is very --
it's something you
have to put in relation
and you cannot have
one constitution."
So, every time Lima Barreto
wrote things like this,
constitution, it's not for us,
he was quoting Nina Rodriguez.
It's not something nave.
And then what Lima
Barreto experiences,
he knew very well the
racial theories that worked
with the ideas of stigmas, no?
That you have extent of
phenomena that could show
that you -- that
you were a person
that carried the degeneration.
For example, anarchism was
considered a collective
that generation.
You know, Barreto
was an anarchist.
Second, [speaking foreign
language] was a stigma
of racial, that generation.
Alienated people.
Another side of that generation.
Lima Barreto's father, known for
[inaudible], he had a problem
with the accounts and
then he became that.
He never came back to life.
His housing [speaking
foreign language] was called
by the neighbors
of the mats house.
So, he was a person very much
against this kind of institution
in Brazil and he considered
this institution a kind
of symbol of Brazil.
Of discrimination, of
racist, of problems of class.
But at the same time when he was
in the hospital the second time
in 1919, there was a moment
that he said that he wrote,
I studied the [speaking
foreign language], the document
that the dialogue that Lima
Barreto had with the person
that took care to -- that said,
you are black or you are white
or you are [speaking
foreign language].
And then there was a moment
that Lima Barreto says,
"I confess, I have stigmas."
This is the moment as a
biographer, as a historian
that you think, "No,
please do not confess."
You cannot change this.
But at the same time
he was carrying on,
he was writing a book, "The
Cemetery of the Living,"
that would be a very very
strong critic of this system.
So, the difference
between Mashado Dajasheesh,
he's a lot of discuss
in my book.
If you compare Mashado
Dajasheesh
and Lima Barreto's life, Mashado
Dajasheesh came from a family
of -- more the structured
family that Lima Barreto.
And Mashado Dajasheesh is not
sure that he was against --
that he was a person that did
not -- was against slave system.
He was. As a public servant
he frequently used to give --
used to charge the owner
-- the slave owners.
But at the same time
in this situation,
very very very beautiful
a person,
because one can't understand
the difference of being a critic
or experiencing this
kind of life.
>> Bryan McCann: Right.
>> >Lilia Schwarcz:
The experience he had
in the hospital was
really really strong
and deep to Lima Barreto.
>> Bryan McCann:
Thank you very much.
Questions from the floor.
>> I would like to ask
about Clara Dos Anjos.
[Inaudible] the main character,
and she's a black girl,
and her name, Clara, is the
opposite of black [inaudible].
And Anjos meant angel.
So, I'd like to discuss
what is in this name?
>> Lilia Schwarcz: Oh.
He -- I don't know your
name talking about this.
>> My name is Ileany
[assumed spelling] Ileany.
>> Lilia Schwarcz: Ileany.
Lima Barreto wrote about it
as Cassi Jones is Cassi Jones.
It's not nave.
And Clara dos Anjos is Clara
dos Anjos, not nave.
So, Clara means a person
that is very -- very white.
No? And Clara was a mulatto.
He describes her as a mulatto.
And in Clara dos Anjos
there is one part --
two paragraphs when he
describes Clara Dos Anjos father
and Clara dos Anjos mother,
that you can see exactly how
he's playing with colors.
In my opinion, Lima Barreto
writes a black literature
in Brazil, because first of all,
the main characters are black
or mestizos or mulattos.
He uses a lot of names.
Olives, he describes
himself like black olive.
Something like this.
And then he's also
he's a black writer,
because color matters for him.
So, if you put together
Clara dos Anjos names
in these two paragraphs and
he tries to describe Joaquim,
Clara dos Anjos father,
and then [inaudible],
Clara dos Anjos mother,
it's very impressing how he
can negotiate with colors.
Think about Anjos,
I just took part
of a [speaking foreign
language],
and the [speaking foreign
language] and the person says
that black girls are
always saying that they want
to be white angels or angels.
But that the teacher says
that an angel is
white, cannot be black.
So, you can see what
Lima Barreto was trying
to say with this, no?
And the deception,
the suddenness
of Clara dos Anjos
it's very impressive.
One thing that touched
me a lot is
that he started writing
Clara dos Anjos
in the first moment he
started writing his diary.
900. And the first
version of Clara dos Anjos,
she ends like a prostitute
and in another version
he kills Cassi Jones.
In another version
she's pregnant.
This is the version we know,
because the last one he signed.
But this is very important for
me, because the critics use it
to say that Lima Barreto
was like writer in a hurry,
that he had no time
to finish his books.
But I think that Lima Barreto
uses another very modern
[inaudible] of unfinished.
Most of his stories he's
frequently rewriting
the stories.
Sometimes as a short story,
sometimes as a chronicle,
sometimes as a journalist.
So it's very impressive to
me that he kept the name.
This one since the beginning
of the novel, Clara dos Anjos.
>> I read the book
many years ago,
and I don't remember the
descriptions of mother
and father or father
and [inaudible].
But I do remember the
last sentence of the book
and she says something
like, "We are nothing."
>> Lilia Schwarcz: We are
nothing in this words.
>> So, I'm thinking
about this, she's Clara,
she's dos Anjos, but she's not.
So, she's nothing.
And it's very...
>> Lilia Schwarcz: Well, she is.
That's the point that
Lima wants to tell you,
because Pedro [speaking
foreign language] the professor,
a colleague of mine in
Princeton now, and we wrote --
we organized together the last
edition of the roots of Brazil
and we tried to show how
and when [inaudible]
changed his book completely.
So we had the five most
important editions.
And we tried to prove
how this is Brazil,
it is a book that moves.
It's not the same book in
36 and the last version
that [speaking foreign
language] put in that.
The same thing happens
with Clara dos Anjos.
So, I agree and I disagree
with you, because depending
on the end, she is a person
that can just be a sad person
and sometimes she's
a person that fights.
So, this is the category
you have unfinished.
So, depending on the
version, you are dealing
with the last one, the one he
signed, but the one he signed,
in my opinion, it's
not the last one.
And that's literature, no?
That's the power of
literature, imagination.
>> Bryan McCann:
That's beautiful.
Yeah
>> I'm [inaudible], I'm here as
a full ride scholar at Howard,
so [inaudible], I'm a
historic [inaudible] I work
with films, [inaudible] a lot.
>> Lilia Schwarcz: Thank you.
>> But, my question, as you
brought us numbers, sad numbers,
not sad as you put
[inaudible] Lima Barreto numbers
[inaudible], I was
curious to ask you
about the affirmative actions
and some years ago you were
against affirmative
actions in Brazil and I want
to know your opinion
about them now.
>> Lilia Schwarcz: I have
to thank you for this.
[speaking foreign language]
changed his mind, no?
Lima Barreto changed his mind.
And I changed my mind and I
said that for a long time.
I think you know I'm working
in affirmative actions
at [inaudible] for
more than 10 years.
And then at that moment it was
a very problematic signing.
I didn't read the last
text, that I wrote that,
that's why I can't
say it publicly.
And it wasn't the -- how can I
say, the text that was there,
[inaudible] and Peter Fry
[assumed spelling], they wrote.
It was connected to a very
particular thing in that moment
and that it transformed the
document in another thing.
I had a lot of problems
about this.
And then I said, "Now,
what I have to do,
I have to prove what's
my opinion."
So, I'm working hard
in affirmative action
in Universe of Sao Paulo.
As you know Universe
of Sao Paulo is the biggest
university in South America.
I'm not saying that's the best,
it's the biggest in numbers, no?
Sometimes we are
falling down the hill.
But it's a numbers, nobody
is going to believe me.
And Universe of Sao Paulo
it's also very the last one
to have this kind of problem.
So, I'm very much in favor
of affirmative action
for various reasons.
I'm going to say two of them.
One of them I gave
you the answer today.
I wrote -- I'm writing
a lot of assess,
showing how Brazil is a
very unequal country and how
in this very unequal
country race is a plus.
It's more than equal.
No? So, I'm for affirmative
actions because we had a past.
A present past.
And we have to deal
with this present past.
But I'm also for affirmative
actions, and that was my problem
in Universe of Sao Paulo
for very positive reasons.
Because I think diversity
is always more.
That we need diversity.
That we'll have a
better university
if you have more
diversity in the university.
And I'm not talking
just about the students.
I'm talking about the
public administration,
I'm talking about
the professors.
So, if I look around
I'm always --
now I'm always for
affirmative action.
At that moment my thought in
race as a biological catholic,
I use it to say things
like this.
We do not have racist,
we have one race.
So, what's wrong.
But then for a long time in
working with social race,
like Bryan asked me
in a very casual way.
So, if you think
about social race,
what we are saying is
we are in one race,
but the social creates this very
hot difference in our society.
And as an anthropologist,
because I'm a mix of a historian
and an anthropologist, I think
that culture is a
kind of second nature.
So, it's so strong as nature.
So, thank you for your question.
>> Happy to [inaudible],
because I was very sad
when I saw your name
on that list.
>> Lilia Schwarcz:
Yeah, a long time ago.
[inaudible] and I'm very
proud of changing my mind, no?
>> thank you so much.
>> My name is [inaudible] and
I want to thank the Library
for being here and
coordinating your visit
with the [inaudible] meeting,
so that's just [inaudible]
to have you here.
And, so, as a anthropologist,
my question is less literary
and less historic and more about
race from an import perspective.
So, I'm curious in your
discussion about color
versus race and I understand
the distinction you are making,
I have had lots of experiences
in my own research talking
to Brazilians where
they at one point back
when I was doing my dissertation
research, I handed out surveys
of a racial category and that
was a very confusing question
and I got answers that were sort
of boggle the American mind.
Where people would say
to me, "Well, my race,
do you mean in the summer when
I have a tan or in the dark
or in the winter or when
there's not as much sun?"
And these are things that don't
make any sense to Americans.
I give that example in my
classes on US based relations.
So I think these are things that
don't make sense to Americans.
But I'm curious in one of
the things you said here,
understanding those
distinction and understanding
that Brazil has a very
different racial history,
very different day to
day experience with race.
And people's understanding,
identity also
in terms of how they identify.
I'm going to apologize for
a very targeted question,
but I'm curious, would you say
that their Brazil has
different form of racism?
Or do you believe that the
racism, what it's based on,
like the [inaudible] hierarchy
is the same and just sort
of the manifestations of
it that are different?
I mean, I guess I'm asking what
has been an essential question
to the field of [inaudible]
relations.
So, I hate to pin you down.
You can go anywhere you
want on the answer on this,
just want to hear your response.
>> Lilia Schwarcz:
Very good questions.
We have like four hours?
Thank you so much.
>> I do.
>> Lilia Schwarcz:
Thank you so much.
First of all, if I understood
your beautiful question,
I think I would describe
racism is racist.
There was a moment when some
of the scholars in Brazil
in the 30s and 40s used to
describe color and race --
used to oppose race and color
in a sense that race is --
color is better than race.
Color is [inaudible]
and race is not.
I do not agree with that.
I think that color is
a very perverse system.
Very [inaudible] naturalized,
invisible form of racist.
And more than this,
it's a very private form
of dealing with racist.
The thing is, in public's
view, we are not going to talk
about this, but in private, yes.
And color is a -- I think
it's a very very complex way
of classification.
It's a social marker
of difference.
That you put together
different marks like color,
class, sometimes region.
Sometimes religion also.
So, it's a way of not
saying and saying.
It's a way of [inaudible]
in a very strong language.
Without saying that we do it.
We -- I work in a group called
[inaudible] that we are study.
The first thing I would
say to you is it depends
on the region of Brazil.
It's completely different.
If you ask your question
in the south you will
have one kind of answer.
If you go to the [inaudible]
and ask another question you're
going to receive another answer.
I guess you will not
receive your answer.
And then if you go to the
center of Brazil, also.
So, Brazil as the United
States I think it has a form
of a continent, and the
reality of a continent.
But even so, if you
go to, for example,
to a place like [speaking
foreign language],
I interviewed a [speaking
I know this person,
this man, [inaudible].
He wanted to talk with me,
he knew the subject I wanted
to talk with him and he --
and eventually when I opened
the door and start talk
to him he said to me,
"you know, go," you know,
because in Brazil
you can go or no go,
[speaking foreign language].
The moment -- during
the moment I was back,
my life was very different.
So, you can smile all this
and can think it's a joke.
It's not a joke.
It's the same story we are
reading here in Lima Barreto,
that the first time he
was described as white,
because he was a writer,
because he was a public servant.
And the second time he was a
[speaking foreign language],
because he was [inaudible],
he was tired.
You know? So, this is the
way people use color, by --
but in my opinion, I have a lot
of colleagues here that can talk
and agree or disagree with me,
things are changing in Brazil.
Now you can talk about
having black proud.
You can talk about different
origins, you can talk
about different Africans
in Brazil.
So, in my opinion things
are really changing.
And it's not so easy to say,
"No, we do not have this kind
of thing, or this kind
of thing of racist."
But at the same time when
I wrote that book, "Brazil,
a Biography," together
with Heloisa,
we said we historians
we like to say
that history is a
game of changing.
But history can be
a very stubborn way
of repeating things.
So, in 1988 at Universe of Sao
Paulo we finished our research
that we asked Brazilians
about racial discrimination.
And it was very simple,
we asked Brazilians,
the first question
was, "Do you have --
do you feel discrimination now?"
96% of the answers were no.
The second question was,
"Do you know a person
that felt -- was discriminated?"
And 99% of the answers were yes.
And the third, "if you said yes,
try to describe the
relationship you have."
And people used to say things
like this, "My neighbor,
my grandmother, my
brother, my boyfriend."
So, the formal conclusion was
that every Brazilian thinks
he's an island of race
or democracy surrounded
by races everywhere.
But the surprise is
that [inaudible] magazine
just finished a new research
and again you can see this
kind of thing, you know.
We had this public face.
As an anthropologist and I'm a
very much a [inaudible] person,
no, I think that myth
it's not something
that -- it's not alive.
Myth, the structure of
the myths is that --
the myth tells you not
the truth, but tells you
about contradictions
of this society.
So we have this very base root
myth of race of democracy.
The problem is, it's not
a lie, it's not a lie,
because it's a public
representation.
It's something very private
that he people want to believe.
And why affirmative action is
so important in our quota system
and it's so important
in our country,
because we have to
talk about this.
The worse place to
live is invisibility.
And in Brazil this idea of
playing with colors has a color
of invisibility, has the color
of [speaking foreign language].
And that's a problem.
>> Bryan McCann: I think
that's potentially a brilliant
conclusion to the session there.
Is there any further questions?
I think we can't really
do any better than that.
That sums it up very
beautifully.
Thank you so much.
>> Lilia Schwarcz:
thank you for the class.
[ Applause ]
>> Thank you.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.